[Música]
donde están las personas como yo las
personas que se ven como yo porque no
hay más personas afrodescendientes en
estos espacios
a lo largo de mi vida
estas preguntas me ha acompañado una y
otra vez
me pasó en el colegio donde yo era la
única persona fue ascendiente de mi
clase donde estaban los demás
también me pasaron espacios en los que
para mí era muy natural hallar me de
desarrollarme o estar
trataba de justificar la situación
pensando que quizás estar en espacios
muy pequeños que cuando fuera espacios
más grandes los encontraría que había
tenido mala suerte
o que quizás solamente había sido
casualidad en no encontrarlos lo que
pasó luego es que fui yendo espacios más
amplios como la universidad y tampoco
los encontraba donde estaban los demás
empecé a darme cuenta de mi entorno y no
estaban
aprendí en la televisión y no estaban
media los ministros a los gobernantes a
las autoridades y no estaban
miraba a los líderes de opinión a los
comentaristas y no estaban
y poco a poco empecé a darme cuenta que
no encontrarlos no era una casualidad
sino que había algo mucho más fuerte que
estaba pasando y que yo no estaba viendo
anteriormente
habían diferencias eran brechas
relacionadas a lo que comúnmente
conocemos como racismo
el racismo agrupa a las personas por las
maneras en las cuales se ven y
establecen mecanismos que les dan más o
menos valor en la sociedad
a partir de esos mecanismos establece
jerarquías y les brinda más o menos
derechos
las personas afrodescendientes en el
perú han sido excluidas históricamente
eso nos genera una situación bastante
compleja y muy distinta a la de otras
poblaciones
fue muy difícil darme cuenta que no
encontrarlos no era una casualidad
porque lo que pasaba conmigo estaba
relacionada a la excepcionalidad y no a
lo que comúnmente se espera de las
personas afrodescendientes en un país
como el perú
como les mencioné antes el racismo
genera diferencias significativas en el
acceso a oportunidades
esto suena fácil de decir verdad menos
oportunidades
pero alguna vez nos hemos puesto a
pensar de verdad qué significa tener
menos oportunidades
el racismo influye de manera real en la
trayectoria de vida de las personas y
genera diferencias en lo que podría ser
su experiencia humana
el racismo marca finalmente una
diferencia en el ejercicio de los
derechos para graficar mejor lo que les
estoy contando
les voy a compartir una experiencia
personal me pasó cuando tenía 23 o 24
años estaba recogiendo información con
la organización en la que participó
activamente hasta hoy el trabajo de
campo tenía como objetivo poder conocer
las expectativas educativas y también
saber cuáles eran las limitantes que
tenían los jóvenes y las jóvenes
afrodescendientes para poder acceder a
educación superior me tocó entonces
conversar con una muchacha que tenía más
o menos mi edad y cuando le pregunté
sobre sus expectativas ella me contó que
siempre había querido ser abogada
pero que le habían hecho entender que
las personas que se veían como ella no
servían para ir a la universidad
me dijo que las personas como ella no
servimos para ir a la universidad
me quedé fría
entendí como el racismo podía haber
impactado la vida de esta mujer que
había sido cambiada totalmente por una
serie de estereotipos y prejuicios
y entendí además porque nos resulta
extraño que solamente el 11 por ciento
de la población afrodescendiente logre
tener estudios superiores en el perú
solamente el 11 por ciento de la
población afroperuana logra tener
estudios superiores
al escucharlo también entendí como los
insultos los agravios y los estereotipos
no solamente impactan en nuestras
interacciones con las demás personas
sino que además nos cambian por dentro y
afectan nuestras expectativas y nuestras
percepciones
es muy injusto que el racismo determine
la trayectoria de vida de una persona
en el perú la población afrodescendiente
no solamente tiene menor acceso a
educación sino que también presenta
menores niveles en acceso a servicios de
salud y se ve afectada en sus niveles de
ingresos
más de un tercio de la población
afroperuana vive con 750 soles al mes o
menos
además de eso tienen varias necesidades
básicas insatisfechas
si miramos por ejemplo el encuesta
nacional de hogares
podremos ver que la condición de
hacinamiento en hogares afroperuanos es
de 13.5 este porcentaje es casi tres
veces más que el promedio nacional
además de eso la población afroperuana
indica en porcentajes muy altos que la
discriminación es una causa de la
pobreza lo que hace el racismo
finalmente es determinar cuáles son los
espacios que debería ocupar un grupo de
personas en la sociedad
a partir de estos espacios se utiliza
como herramientas los estereotipos y los
prejuicios
para construir esta ciudad sobre cómo
deberían ser o cómo deberían comportarse
ciertas personas seguramente esos
estereotipos son familiares para muchos
de ustedes
hablemos con honestidad
si estuvieran caminando por la calle de
noche y vieron a un hombre
afrodescendiente acercarse ustedes
querían
probablemente muchos y muchos de ustedes
escogería un fuerte su cartera o su
maletín y cruzaría en la calle ante el
peligro inminente
este es solo uno de varios estereotipos
que al ser reproducidos de manera masiva
contribuyen a mantener una sociedad en
la que cada persona tiene un lugar
donde cada persona ocupa un lugar y no
puede salir de ese lugar
lo que hace el racismo dejarnos saber
cuáles son estos límites que no
deberíamos cruzar
entender el racismo hacia las personas
afro peruanas me hizo darme cuenta de
las brechas tan grandes que tenemos en
un país tan diverso como el perú
pero también me hizo darme cuenta de
todo lo demás que estaba pasando
me hizo pensar cuán intenso es el
racismo y cuando nos afecta
a partir de eso lo que hice fatal y los
muy fácilmente y pude ver que la
discriminación y las diferencias en el
vidente acceso oportunidades no eran una
coincidencia
en las poblaciones quechuas aymaras y
amazónicas por ejemplo se identifica que
la discriminación se genera por
cuestiones relacionadas a lo que
entendemos como signos culturales los
signos culturales están asociados a las
lenguas al hablar a la vestimenta a las
costumbres
en el caso de la población afroperuana
por otro lado podemos ver que la
discriminación se genera mayormente por
cuestiones que tienen que ver con el
aspecto físico y los rasgos
es decir tienen que ver con el color de
la piel con la manera en la que llevamos
nuestro cabello o con la manera en la
cual expresamos nuestra cultura y
nuestras costumbres alguna vez nos hemos
puesto a pensar qué pasaría si el
racismo no existiera
nos hemos puesto a pensar cuántas
posibilidades podrían tener miles de
personas que hoy se ven impedidas de
ejercer su ciudadanía de manera plena
por ejemplo últimamente cuando hablamos
de inclusión y de paridad hacemos
hincapié en que la desigualdad de género
nos cuesta dinero y que las sociedades
pierden cuando no incluyen a las mujeres
a mí me parece urgente y necesario hacer
estas comparaciones
sin embargo no he dejado de pensar si
alguna vez nos hemos puesto a
reflexionar sobre qué pasaría si el
racismo en el perú no existiera
cuando le cuesta al perú no incluir a
todas las personas y brindarles las
mismas oportunidades
nos hemos puesto a pensar cuánto nos
podríamos desarrollar como país se
racismo no estuviera presente
yo he dejado de preguntarme
cómo sería el perú sin racismo
cómo sería la vida de la muchacha de la
que les hablé sin racismo
cómo sería mi vida sin racismo
cuando pensamos en las posibilidades
limitadas que tiene la población
afrodescendiente para poder acceder a
educación superior
podemos entender que el hecho que yo
esté aquí hoy parada hablándoles estos
temas no me convierte en una
superheroína
sino una excepción en un sistema que
lamentablemente está hecho para que
personas que se ven como yo no logren
sus objetivos en la vida
el activismo anti racista me llevó a ver
que existían brechas muy grandes que
afectaban a las personas
afrodescendientes
pero mi experiencia de vida me enseñó
que esa no es la única brecha que me
atraviesa
porque además de ser afrodescendiente
soy mujer y eso me coloca en una
posición totalmente distinta
soy una mujer afro peruana y eso hace
que mis experiencias de vida sean mucho
más complejas
cuando pienso en mí como trascendente o
pienso en mí como mujer pienso en como
estos dos aspectos de mi vida que forman
parte fundamental de mi identidad
se combina para generar experiencias de
vida y trayectorias de vida totalmente
diferentes
probablemente mi experiencia sea
distinta de aquellas personas que
solamente se identifican como
afrodescendientes o solamente se
identifican con mujeres
pueden verlo es imposible que solamente
le afecte el racismo o solamente me
afecta el sexismo
en este punto lo que me parece
importante es contarles de un concepto
básico para el entendimiento de las
desigualdades este concepto es el
concepto de intersección alidad
la intersección alidad fue planteada
porque mi creencia hace ya varios años y
es básicamente un concepto que se
utiliza para entender como el sexismo y
el racismo afecta la vida de las mujeres
afroamericanos
aunque originalmente fue creado con este
propósito lo que ha pasado es que se ha
convertido en una herramienta de
análisis muy útil para poder entender
cómo las personas pueden tener
diferentes identidades y esas
identidades les pueden generar
afectaciones diferentes como
consecuencia de las mismas
sobre todo cuando estamos pensando en
que estas identidades son identidades
que no han sido valoradas de manera
correcta en la sociedad
cuando entendí lo que estaba pasando con
este concepto mi cerebro explotó con
preguntas
empecé a preguntarme qué otras cosas no
estaba mirando y que estaba pasando con
otros grupos que también se veían
afectados por sistemas de opresión
empecé a preguntarme por ejemplo por los
pueblos indígenas la población lgtb más
o las mujeres
también empecé a preguntarme por todos
los otros grupos que no entran dentro de
esta lógica de la normalidad y me fue
inevitable cuestionarme cómo vivimos las
personas que no corresponde mos con
estas lógicas y que no actuamos de
acuerdo a lo que se espera de nosotros
si entendemos que una persona puede
sufrir múltiples opresiones al tener dos
o más identidades
podremos ver que en muchos casos estamos
hablando no de una brecha sino de más de
una y que estas brechas se sobreponen y
se entrecruzan es vital entender este
concepto porque así podremos garantizar
que todas las personas tengan las mismas
oportunidades y que además puedan
ejercer su ciudadanía de manera plena
es muy importante que las políticas y
las acciones que hagamos para reducir
brechas contemplen una mirada
interseccional porque si no podríamos
estar dejando de lado muchos factores
que son importantes
hemos pensado por ejemplo si las
políticas de igualdad de género tienen
en cuenta el enfoque étnico para poder
mirar la diversidad de todas las mujeres
o si en caso las políticas con enfoque
étnico o políticas para población
afroperuana tienen en cuenta el enfoque
de género
si la respuesta es negativa
lo que pasa es que perdemos una mirada
bastante panorámica y hacemos que muchas
personas queden fuera de estas acciones
o estas políticas
pensemos por ejemplo qué pasa con una
mujer indígena que a su vez es joven y
vive en el ámbito rural
lo que pasa con una mujer trans que a su
vez es afrodescendiente
todas sus mujeres pero el género no es
lo único que las atraviesa y si queremos
mirarlas y atenderlas tendremos que ver
otros factores como la etnicidad la edad
la ubicación geográfica o la identidad
de género
verlas únicamente como mujeres nos hará
perder perspectiva sobre cuáles son
aquellas cosas en las que necesitamos
trabajar para poder garantizarles una
mejor calidad de vida
la intersección alidad importa
importa porque verla nos permitirá
identificar que cuando diferentes
identidades confluyen se pueden generar
mayores situaciones de opresión
esto pasa por ejemplo con las mujeres
afro personas rurales cuyos niveles de
analfabetismo alcanzan el 24.1 por
ciento
este nivel es casi tres veces mayor que
el nivel de analfabetismo a nivel
nacional
inclusive ser una mujer a preparar en el
ámbito rural es muy diferente de ser una
mujer afro peruana en el ámbito urbano
ya que si seguimos mirando el
analfabetismo como una variable podremos
observar que las mujeres afro planas
rurales tienen una tasa casi 5 veces
mayor que las mujeres preparadas en el
ámbito urbano
que tienen un promedio de 5.5 por ciento
de la brecha son cinco veces más como
bien lo que pasa cuando tomamos un
indicador como ejemplo
es que encontramos que las diferentes
identidades de una persona pueden
generar resultados completamente
distintos para sus experiencias humanas
lo que quería contarles a lo largo de la
charla es que es vital entender que las
diferencias y estas jerarquías que
hacemos entre las personas generan
afectaciones reales en la trayectoria de
vida me refiero a todo tipo de
afectaciones como el racismo el machismo
el sexismo o la homofobia
estas afectaciones además pueden verse
multiplicadas cuando una o más
identidades confluyen generando
discriminaciones y profundizando mucho
más las brechas
lo que tenemos que hacer
es aprender a ver estas brechas poniendo
en unos lentes especiales que tengan en
cuenta el enfoque de la intersección
alidad
más allá de eso necesitamos detenernos a
pensar en cuál es la base del problema
el problema es que no estamos mirando la
diferencia como algo positivo que da
valor y enriquece
al contrario hemos seguido utilizando
las diferencias de las personas para
poder mantener reproducir y justificar
las desigualdades
hemos aceptado esta falsa idea de
igualdad que en la práctica no existe y
hemos pensado que quienes se identifican
con identidades distintas somos el
problema
lo que tenemos que empezar a pensar es
cómo hacer para que cada persona
independientemente de sus identidades
pueda ser valorada de la misma manera en
la sociedad
nos hace falta ser muy conscientes de lo
que nos afecta pero también de aquello
que nos duele y nos hace falta tener esa
mirada interseccional de la que les
estaba hablando
porque nos ayudará a tener una visión
panorámica de las distintas maneras en
las cuales la desigualdad opera
para hacernos cargo es vital que
empecemos a reconocernos como parte del
problema
cuando hablemos de racismo por ejemplo
decimos que el 53% de los peruanos y las
peruanas reconoce que la sociedad es
racista o muy racista pero solamente el
8% se autoidentifica como parte del
problema
esta incapacidad que tenemos para poder
asumir nuestra participación en un
problema de magnitudes estructurales nos
hace responsables en una sociedad que
sigue habiendo la diversidad como una
oportunidad como un problema y no como
una oportunidad
solamente cuando entendamos que este
sistema ha sido creado y reproducido
para poder mantener desigualdades
podremos comprender que es un deber
poder hacernos cargo de nuestro racismo
y reflexionar de manera consciente sobre
nuestras acciones solamente cuando
aprendamos a reconocer el valor de la
diferencia ya reconocer como valiosas
todas las características que nos hacen
seres distintos
podremos tomar acción y dejar de
utilizar la diversidad como algo nominal
para garantizar que todas las personas
puedan tener las mismas oportunidades
para alcanzar su mayor potencial
independientemente de cómo se vean aquí
en amen o de donde vengan
sé que lo que les digo es mucho más
fácil de decir que de hacer
pero creo que tenemos una
responsabilidad individual en un
problema colectivo
tenemos que aprender a reflexionar como
seres humanos y como personas que
ejercemos nuestra ciudadanía pero
también como tomadores de decisiones
esto nos va a permitir reconocer
nuestros privilegios y ver cómo podemos
utilizarlos para visibilizar
problemáticas y poder vender
alternativas de solución que puedan
garantizar mejores condiciones de vida
para todas las personas
este es el momento en el que podemos
empezar a construir la sociedad que
merecemos gracias
[Música]